c'è un ragazzo tipo invece i neri per
caso dobbiamo fare
non potrei fare io faccio il beat ok vai
io che posso fare il mio ipad i tuoi
figli ti prego cia ragazzi siamo noi che
non siamo dei cantanti in purtroppo non
so se avete notato di questa cosa siamo
io pietro e francesco oggi qua sono
praticamente uscite nuove rischi al
gusto non so se hai mai fatto un video
sulle liste giusto ma io l'ho fatto una
volta sono le bustine molla qua faccio
io praticamente nelle nuove rischia
giusto dal titolo ave l'avrete già
capito sono più siglata soddisfarmi
parlare non sanno cosa cambia dall'una
all'altra cambiano i livelli di
piccantezza quindi il gusto è buono però
sono piccanti a te piace il piccante ma
la faccia mi sa di sì a te piace più
cantati dai a me fa vomitare il piccante
prova allora prima e lingua infuocata si
chiama la verde ed è una stella di
piccantezza quindi e easy sulla verde il
gusto mela tra l'altro è buono la
seconda si chiama bomba calabrese cosa
giallo
due stelle di piccantezza il gusto e
limone una verde e piccante livello
piccantezza uno è una verde e alla mela
senza stare piccante quindi quella
gialla può essere sia piccante livello
26 anno muore ho capito perfetti
l'ultima e peperoncino atomico il gusto
non te lo leggo dai loro gusto e fragola
pro ma non è il gusto che la piccantezza
che devo dire
abbiamo il ruota e rotino siamo su di
hey girl over che ormai diventato il
nostro gioco delle challenge ogni volta
che qualcuno sbaglia tirerà la ruota e
in base a quello che uscirà si mangerà
caramello nel caso e scambia ancora che
per katy fuggire aiuta roba bianca prima
giallini e mangia niente è uno dei corsi
il piano dai sei un uomo intuirono
capito non avete capito tipo di creatura
mito lo stesso tavolo il nuovo mezzo
uomo e mezzo youtuber e parto io parlo
con tutti noi
vai ok snap chat classe come di più
perché i meno meno a prescindere mai
toccate calcaterra by zio o bozzett di
più a se sia giusto quindi così da poco
chiaro chiamare ci siamo ci siate dice
addio semmai di più da miley cyrus fai
vedere le tue mosse di kung fu miley
grande mai e contribuì poi però hannah
montana
un cargo di più chicago bulls di più di
marmo nulla di meno
gira gira per il uscito dalla c 6 vani
giallo limone me ne vado già applicando
così per un po sembra non cela mourinho
ed eto'o
magari le orecchie bene cioè a quest'ora
avremmo pagato dai pompieri playgame
greenbelt auro richter questo sei tu
pietro now
mi sorprende vita fortissimo da twist e
sempre più piccante ma basta tourist ma
come si sa quale sempre mirava librai
il bellissimo recita 2000 ma così poco i
thai qui che fan tatuaggi
io non ti considera agosto a questo è
così tanto o e giallo è giallo e rosso
piero e dai questa caravelle morpheus
spillo dove rapito da blu morpheus ai
topi camp nou lega no rega non sento già
sento già lega ma dopo bicchiere aspetta
ragazzi ci sono i momenti addio non
spetta a sentir male da millar deve
essere obesi che chiedo è latte al latte
più bravo è l'attivazione da millar
miani sulla realizzati sono giuro
datemi da qui dove saputo ma è così
ficcante attaccare questo nuovo lancio
bicchiere lega da madonna sto morire ma
non funziona ma chi è che ha detto nel
latte non fa passare non è vero ma
veniamo qua non possano avanti sempre
un'altra mora in altra un'altra cosa
free and games per haga non va via
veloce
hong kong giappone dai ris matichon kong
no no premetto con l'imbuto veloce
azione e rossori nuova che oggi ci vuole
bene qualcuno mai pietro fi pan dan con
la maglia dai ok la beccaccia
no è una buona per adesso che sfiga
allsync jin ping semmai di meno ma
perché in cina hanno l'internet di
stretta che maradona di l'ires è
bravissimo a lungo l'area erano fatte
più ricercate ma quello che sono sicuro
guarda secondo me lo ero
missing person ma come non sta scritto
quello per i nodi meno ma dai di meno
dai artefici del tuo destino della
frattona credit tutte le fashion stanno
uscendo giuro tutte e tre caro partiamo
con la perdita il cast faster da tè
verde giallo rosso ma sai che ti dico
hai fatto davvero di che ho fatto non
sai neanche quali quelle sta picchiando
in tutto come se picchiano tutte tra si
fa tutte non sento il sapore pian piano
sempre di più non sai neanche quale
quello che è brutto potrebbe stare la
rossa se vai in bagno e quello ero lì a
destra
la donna proprio tutti dalla bottiglia
dovuti donne che pur lottando non è lo
nego ottima prendi tutto quel è il
numero dei pompieri prima che pietro lo
sai vado ad altro mondo di facebook
controller o egiziano pyramid penso
delle piramidi egizie nostro nome di
meno
melo già giocato non sapevo che
religiosi di più di mille son poche 700
mila secondo cioè niente devo andare 73
dai vieni qualche per coinvolti in
questa cosa amico mio però vivo il
bianco il primo vescovo lo giuro
incredibile se sei un uomo ma non lo
sapevo che non eri un uomo dai fanno per
le mie views non ne mangio tutte e tre
insieme
se tu le mangi e tre insieme va bene dai
hanno adesso adesso miei file noi
insieme ad assieme ci sta solo per
vederti soffrire anche non facciamo con
francesco anche no spero che fai l'uovo
e lo facciamo tutti e tre team che
sbagliano dobbiamo pagare noi scusami
farmi capire all'ingente vai non sento
niente questa volta gli è un peccato
della rossa si no raga lanciato fatto io
mi sa che sono un peccatore rossa io il
nostro non a mira stavolta buonissimo ha
regalato beccate tutte loew un occhio
c'è un occhio rosso ma se arriviamo a 10
me li faccio alla goccia ma sei pazzo ma
soldi tu mi rifaccio alla classe esce a
10 degli arriverà 10 però si fa
continuiamo che con aria ma adesso
invece 96 mila min diesel e keith
schilling ma nessuno ha basato il
guenzati immagino fisiologia avendo io
lavoro maurizio il trucco e non
concentrarsi su quello che hai fatto
confishop di più goffi shop grande sei
ok drive crossfit ok trascritto las
vegas
las vegas il golden gate bridge
secondo minimi meno di las vegas cioè la
draga così poco ma sicuramente non ci
volete che succeda gara di miu miu
pietro di poco però scusami perché c'è
scritto nadia toffa e c'è un vulcano di
rieti e no dico di più gesù pd nadia
toffa bene cosmedin sorge di meno
funzione siamo a 7 vai vai eticamente
più di qualche a 2 dai a ok a cavour a
tutti e tutte le tue mani e 31 anni
non so cosa sia stato un rosso di dio e
giapponese quindi più sicuro
amici miei bevi già da latte direi che
possiamo concludere questa partita
allora lui pietro ha detto che si
sarebbe mangiato tutti questi nel caso
fossimo arrivati a 10 ma noi siamo buoni
noi siamo buoni e oggi facciamo un'altra
cosa questi qua non te li mangi se ne
mangi solo 44 però tutte rosse
no dai almeno ti ho risparmiato vinti
caramelle ma ne mangi 4 pro così
appendino una volta tutte insieme
vai nel mentre io faccia altro nel video
quindi ragazzi spero che video vi sia
piaciuto volevo dirvi che il rischio
gusto comunque le trovate in edicola al
solito subito che è piaciuta cento
comuni della descrizione sono state
questi schiette v noi ci vediamo dopo ci
vediamo come ci rivediamo a un prossimo
video da ragazzi
cosa non arriva
[Musica]